did you ever learn magic or anything
like that i did
how did you know you could see it yeah
the best a little bit
uh yeah i did magic for a little bit
damn that's comedian's arch nemesis i
know
yeah i did it i was kind of good too i
could see you doing good magic
yeah i have good hands for it liquid
hands
but uh yeah i did that for a little bit
tricked my family a couple times
and then i fell off gotten a dance you
know yeah
that's a weird day when you're leaving
the magic scene it's
hard it's dark it's a dark night of the
soul you're walking off and people are
like
just holding out yeah cards for you and
just like i'm not
yeah i can't do it anymore yeah
guys i got to be in reality man yeah
pulling something out of a hat
yeah at a certain point it was just like
just wasn't real enough for me oh yeah
man it's heartbreaking some of the
that i've seen people believe
here's david guy keeps killing himself
yeah he's not doing magic
ever yeah and then he molested some girl
that's what's crazy he's never done
magic
yeah he's like surprised i'm in your 11
year old vagina
or whatever sorry it wasn't 11 it was 17
my bad
but also it was also legal i think did
he get involved in something like that
well also he said he made her disappear
so it was technically an international
heir she's in wyoming now it's illegal
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one